more breaking news right now a grand
jury indicting a mother after police say
they found her one-year-old child dead
and an eight-year-old locked in a
bedroom that child reportedly held in
captivity for a year that is according
to documents we obtained today and these
are just some of the photos the eight
news now investigators obtained from
inside that South Valley Home detectives
say four children lived there including
a 15 year old none of them went to
school and the mother reportedly left
the children alone for days at a time
37-year-old Felina Dees facing seven
counts of child abuse the baby's cause
and manner of death pending right now
and we've also learned CPS received two
reports about the family before that
child's death